[Applause]
let's put the ball in your hands and
improve that madden rating fred
all right
[Applause]
see those were pretty moves fred a
little lt for the hometown
what's up everybody i'm adam lefko and
welcome to another episode of underrated
big
shout out to the great people at state
farm whose rates
are surprisingly great almost as
surprisingly great
as this segway our guest today is fred
warren
now listen you might not know fred
warner but that's because he's the
definition of our show
underrated and we're here to bump up
those madden ratings let's get the
madden ratings adjuster on the line
jake calling madden ratings adjuster
hey adam what's up today got a good one
fred warner
his numbers are great on matted i was
actually very impressed
but i want to make him spectacular okay
all right jake i need you to dial up
that linebacker in san francisco we need
to call fred warner
hit the numbers calling fred
warner
look at him you see him nobody knew the
name
and then the team went to the super bowl
and they all wanted the jersey
fred warner brother how you feeling
feeling good man happy to be out here
trying to see if i can uh boost my stats
a little bit
listen that's what we're doing this is
clint
he's a madden ratings adjuster he's
gonna give you the opportunity
to possibly raise your initial rating
hey man i appreciate it
now listen it is a fact that you
intercepted patma holmes
so clint i think we should target catch
ratings so
what we'd be looking for are you know
difficult types of catches ones where he
really has to reach
or make very athletic plays to make a
play on the ball being you know an
underneath zone defender underneath man
all right okay clint what about juke and
spin move little offense for this
defense guy
yeah you know we're basically gonna
treat him like a ball carrier what we're
going to want to see is
would his moves actually have an impact
on defenders he'll be able to get some
fake outs get some yards after contact
i just want to see his footwork all
right now i'm down i'm down i'm ready
there's a lot at staking all right man
i'm gonna get you the footage thank you
clint
all right thanks all right before we get
started
fred can i show you some footage of you
trying to catch balls in madden
all right let's see it oh
boy in a standstill
okay that's all i needed yeah see those
two right there that's all i needed to
see
what does it feel like to drop it like
that i honestly couldn't tell you i have
no idea what that feels like right there
and that is what we're going to show ea
today okay so here's what we're going to
do
you're going to line up on defense
opposite the quarterback he's going to
hike the ball
motion either left or right then he's
going to fire it
and you've got to make that pick fred
i'm only going to give you five attempts
with our main man quarterback josh
johnson back there winging it
right here so get into position five
rollouts
all right good luck man all right man
appreciate it
all right i'm on him
[Music]
oh that is a strong start fred warner
oh working up a sweat
yeah hey we working out here i just
don't know how your change of direction
is so low
we gotta get that up to at least 95 come
on that's what i'm saying
[Music]
what was that eye for you nailed it that
could have been cleaner
okay okay
[Music]
oh yeah oh man what happened then
hey he threw that on the line
all right fred
to the house see
fred i'm looking at how you were running
there at the end yeah that's what i want
from you more than anything
it's not just the pick it's the six
right
so that's why i think we need to zero in
on your spin and juke moves next
come on come on i need you to see this
madden footage
because it's not good we gotta get those
spin
and juke move ratings up let me see man
oh no that's not it oh
you're not duking it oh no he's not
juking anybody with that
i'm gonna get his sticks yeah that's not
the one come on
we gotta we gotta boost that up man you
know that so i talked to ea
and to improve your spin or juke move
there's a few things that we gotta focus
on
all right i'm gonna send you through an
obstacle course full of tackling dummies
and as you get through it you're gonna
need to show off your best moves
as you approach each dummy it is your
choice
whether you're gonna spin or juke
they're going to be looking for footwork
misdirection and acceleration out of
each move
and you got to give them that nod
all right head movement i see okay get
the head movement in there okay
let's put the ball in your hands and
improve that madden rating fred
let's do it
i think that's a touchdown find no one
all right let's put another one on tape
fred
all right
see those were pretty moves fred lt for
the
for the hometown and that spin man it
looked just like the way you rushed the
passer
surprisingly great that's how you know
that it's a crisp one
[Music]
my favorite part about all this has been
your touchdown celebration
i don't know if that's a good thing or a
bad thing but my celebrations
i only had one touchdown last year and i
was dead tired so i couldn't celebrate
but well my man you look good today and
before i
send this tape to madden are you feeling
confident about your performance out
here
is there anything you're nervous about
them seeing i mean the one pass
yeah maybe but uh
at the end of the day i thought i got
enough good stuff on tape today you know
to uh to boost my stats well the guys
over at ea
they are sticklers about these ratings
so if i have to get you on a call with
them
to further make the case are you okay
with that all right i'm down with that
i'm here for you fred i appreciate you
adam it's all love
fred warner the man the legend come on
i tried to tell you clint he's a baller
he's a shot caller he does whatever he
wants
uh tell me how great he is i just need
to hear it
hey he looked very athletic in that film
i don't know if you coached him up or
what but he was impressive
okay i don't want you to make your
decisions yet because it's time to get
fred warner on the call
you're gonna have to say this to his
face
and there he is tucked away looking
super
how you feeling fred how you living hey
man i'm doing well doing well i'm glad i
could be here
it's time for the reason we're here
clint i'd like to now
have you break down what you saw on the
submission and where we will be with the
ratings
all right so let's start with catch he's
gonna go up one point in catch he was
a 71 which put him at seventh best at
the middle linebacker position
he's now tied for sixth best at a 72
catch rating okay okay improvement now
what
what's really going to make you happy is
your athleticism
on the special moves the spin and the
juke is juke's going up seven points
from 52
to 59. hey he's now the 23rd battle
fred you're actually going to go up 12
points in the spin rating
okay okay 12. going up from a 41
to a 53 man hey now we're talking
now we're talking okay and with all of
that said
it is fred warner underrated fred warner
is
a little bit underrated and we are going
to make some adjustments
hey that's not bad at all you know we
still we still want to keep climbing
though that's that's just a start
for sure but when you put on madden and
you look through your ratings
and you see them from where they were to
where they are how sweet does that feel
oh it feels the best you know yeah you
guys would be surprised how much madden
really means to the players man it's a
big deal yes
and just like that we did it thank you
clint thank you fred
thank you guys for watching underrated
and remember
you are only underrated if people don't
know how surprisingly great
you are that was a state farm blood they
paid for this they deserve it
[Music]
you like what you just saw subscribe to
bleacher report on youtube
for more underrated